Donald Trump is now Furious that Ron
DeSantis stole one of his lines but the
truth is that Trump stole the line from
Reagan they're just stealing the same
stuff from each other back and forth
okay talking points memo article Trump
attacked DeSantis for blatantly
plagiarizing a speech line that Trump
actually took from Reagan
Trump actually took from Reagan the line
is the Great American comeback so team
Trump published this video of trump
using the line in 2020 and then DeSantis
using it now meaning to prove that
DeSantis stole it from Trump three years
ago we launched the Great American
comeback right tonight I stand before
you to share the incredible results
I'm Ron DeSantis and I'm running for
president to lead our Great American
comeback
so this is like the perfect microcosm of
what I expect the 2024 Republican
primary to be Trump attacked DeSantis
for stealing the phrase great American
comeback in reality Trump took the term
from Ronald Reagan Trump didn't invent
it by the way he also didn't accomplish
the Great American comeback but that's a
different thing if you do a Lexus Nexus
search for that term you have hundreds
of pages of results okay that the phrase
great American comeback has been used in
speeches for so long but you go back to
Reagan's State of the Union speech in I
believe it's 86 and there it was that
the uh in that particular speech Reagan
bragged about 37 straight months of
economic growth and falling interest
rates and he said it's because of
conservative values and he talked about
the Great American comeback so Trump
didn't invent it if you want to argue
that anybody has like a claim to these
phrases it would be Reagan also
important Trump didn't make up make
America great again Reagan used a
slightly different version of it back in
1980 where he said let's make America
great again let's make America great
again so my view is these are not such
unique phrases
that anybody really holds a right or or
not obviously it's not a legal right but
even sort of like a moral right to them
these are very general phrases in many
ways but to the extent that the idea is
that these are unique messages from
Republican candidates they're not and
Trump yelling at someone for stealing
something from him that he already stole
from someone else is uh pretty damn
funny I expect this to be exactly the
type of issue that these Republicans
argue about during the uh during this
campaign now one other just like kind of
funny thing you might have noticed that
in that ad Ron DeSantis pronounced his
name d santis this is like a kind of
funny thing
run DeSantis in older videos used to
pronounce his last name d santis and
then more recently while he's been
Governor it's been DeSantis and then in
that video he went back to DeSantis and
it's all kind of weird Trump posted
about this himself to his platform truth
social truth Central where he put have
you heard that Rob de sanctimonious
wants to change his name again he's
demanding that people call him DeSantis
rather than DeSantis actually I like Deb
better a nicer flow so I'm happy he's
changing it he gets very upset when
people including reporters don't
pronounce it correctly therefore he
shouldn't mind de sanctimonious this is
going to be the dumbest but possibly the
most corrosive Republican primary I will
have ever covered that's that's what I'm
expecting and that's what I'm preparing
for